there are animals and lots of them
plenty of ways to get an adrenaline rush
and lots of food and unusual food want a
rattlesnake corn dog here you can get it
welcome to the Iowa State Fair an
American Midwest tradition dating back
to
1854. the oldest and largest
agricultural Exposition in America with
about 1 million visitors every year it's
also Iowa's biggest annual event for
presidential candidates all those people
mean one thing
potential voters
and that's why every four years during
election season candidates running for
president descend on the fair to take
part in the political soapbox where
they're given a microphone a captive
audience and 20 minutes to make their
sales pitch I am running as an America
first mega Republican for candidates
it's a chance to drum up votes ahead of
the all-important first in the nation
Iowa caucuses to be held in January here
at the Iowa State Fair it's a rare
opportunity for voters to get up close
and personal with the candidates you
know I'm in the front row five or six
feet away from somebody who may very
well be the next president of the United
States that's an opportunity I'm not
going to pass up thousands of supporters
of Donald Trump came out Saturday to see
the former president speak his support
here is still very strong I'm for Trump
100 but some other voters still have an
open mind I don't know who I'm gonna
vote for yet but that's because I will
want to find out what everybody has to
say I'm
party and
I'm a person I want to vote for someone
who has my values not just my political
party
and it's those undecided voters that
candidates are trying to win over and it
starts here on this Fairground in Middle
America Gabriel Elizondo Al Jazeera Des
Moines Iowa
foreign